If you want to hear how Crypt series such
as Look-See, Troubled Youth, Stoneheart and
Mordeo are all about to collide, then stick
around to the end of this video.
[Intro]
Hello, and welcome to Horror History, I’m
your teacher: Emo Abraham Lincoln.
In today’s lesson we’ve got a lot to cover,
as we’ll be going over the entire timeline
of events in the Crypt TV Monster Universe.
Mordeo, Look-See, Sunny Family Cult and so
much more are apart of this history and we’ve
got over 400 years of lore to discuss.
This lesson is sponsored by Crypt TV.
The earliest known event takes place in 1609,
when Elkridge Falls is established.
This is where the events of Mordeo would later
take place.
In the late 1600s the cursed statue seen in
Stoneheart is created in New England during
the witch trial era.
"She came from up in New England somewhere.
Some witch trial protector of women nonsense."
In 1848, Avon Manor school is established
in the UK and would serve as the setting for
Shelley nearly 200 years later.
Back in the United States though, two more
towns are established, one in Mohawk, New
York in 1853, and one southeast farming town
known as Harbor in 1876, which would later
be terrorized by Crypt monsters like Look-See,
Aponi, Walter and Fluffy.
About 50 years later, The Great Economic Depression
hits the United States, and on March 20th,
1930 in New York City, a banker named Robert
Capshaw kills his entire family upon the closure
of the bank created by him and his brother.
The brother, James Capshaw is forced to leave
New York two years later due to the financial
situation and the death of his youngest son
and he moves his family out to Harbor, which
only consists of some farmhouses at the time.
He starts getting foreclosure notices at the
barn, and since he is unable to let go of
his emotional attachment to his old bank,
Look-See goes after him, however, a gang of
thieves led by eventual YouTuber James Janisse,
shows up at the same time and gets to him
first, and Look-See takes one of them out
as a warning not to get in the way.
One by one, Look-See takes out the thieves
and the rest of Capshaw’s family, each having
some kind of emotional attachment that they
are unable to release.
Only two survivors are left, the cold-hearted
leader of the thieves and the young daughter,
who assists Look-See in completing a ritual
to awaken a second Look-See monster.
I wouldn’t be surprised if the two Look-Sees
started their own twin-themed YouTube channel,
cause that’s the popular thing right now
isn’t it?
Nearly another 50 years go by before the events
of Mordeo in 1979.
It starts with a man who is turned into the
Mordeo for eating flesh in the woods.
What would follow is the first sighting of
a spellbook known as the Crypt Tome.
A man known as The Butcher is in possession
of the Tome and attempts to summon Mordeo
by cutting off another man’s finger and
eating the flesh on the summoning ground.
He wants to be changed into a monster, but
the Queen Mordeo kills him, because the flesh
he ate was not eaten out of desperation.
Meanwhile, a newspaper headline from Mohawk
tells of a continued search for the missing
girl scouts, so Mohawk and Elkridge must be
somewhat close to each other.
The girls stumble across the resurrection
grounds and the Crypt Tome, but the Mordeo
Queen kills one of the girls, causing the
remaining two get into a fight.
One girl bites the other as a form of desperate
self-defense and the other girl slips and
hits her head on a rock.
She brings the Tome to a desolate cabin, where
she says she belongs to the Mordeo and starts
to transform.
When the transformation is complete, she kills
off an injured man, whose girlfriend takes
the book to try to lead her out of the woods
to escape.
The next morning, she’s surrounded by several
Mordeo, and although she is able to make it
to the road, she’s unable to escape their
wrath, where the Tome is once again dropped.
YouTuber Bobby Burns, who apparently was a
part of the Sunny Family Cult in the 70s and
80s finds the book, which leads us to era
of the cult’s possession of the book.
The cult emerges into the mainstream a couple
years after finding the book in 1982, the
year a man peeing on the side of the road
is killed by two cult members on April Fools
Day and a crooked lawyer is stabbed many times
and dumped in a lake, where the calling card
of Sunny Family Cult is found.
The cult gains so much notoriety that in 1994,
two men named Elias and Roger attempt to start
up their own chapter of the Sunny Family Cult.
They capture a scam artist who corrupted one
of their members and stab him to death.
Elias and Rodger create their masks as they
begin recruiting new people in an isolated
location in the western United States.
Roger becomes obsessed with the Crypt Tome,
inspired by the legends of Soot, The Birch,
Aponi, Look-See and Mordeo.
He reads the prophecy… that a girl of seventeen
with violence etched into her soul… at the
moment of her greatest weakness… a blood
sacrifice of four victims and the fifth will
become something.
He has a vision of the girl, who tells him
to “find her.”
Disagreements arise between Elias and Roger
on the values of the cult-- with Roger wanting
to kill everyone involved in a corrupt system,
and Elias only interested snuffing out the
sources of the corruption.
Elias and Roger battle for control of the
cult, and Elias wins.
Roger backs down and continues to hang around
the cult for another year until May 19th 1995
when Roger attacks someone that Elias refuses
to kill, and they ultimately go their separate
ways.
The next tick on the Crypt Timeline takes
place a couple years later across the pond
at Acton Manor, the brother school of Avon
Manor, where a girl named Shelley Carter meets
with her boyfriend, Oliver Greenwood at the
border between the two schools.
He gives her a bracelet, one of his final
gestures to her before being burned alive
in some kind of chemical store room during
science class.
His teacher looked the other way, tired of
Oliver’s constant misbehaviour in class.
The headmistress covers up the accident, not
wanting the school to get bad press.
When Shelley realizes her boyfriend is missing,
she begins to snoop around the school for
clues.
Realizing this, the headmistress takes action
to ensure Shelley does not find anything she
shouldn’t by hiring another student, Heidi,
a girl who already dislikes Shelley, to dispose
of her.
"If you squish this bug for us, we can guarantee
there'll be a place waiting for you at Willowdale
Elite..."
High school would have been so much more interesting
if there were bounties of every student.
Oh wait, I'm a teacher now, I'm not supposed
to say that.
The following year, on graduation day in June
1998, Shelley is strangled by Heidi and two
other classmates.
She watches helplessly as her classmate Celine,
is too afraid to stand up to the bullies and
Shelley meets her demise.
The incident is staged as a suicide, and they
hang Shelley’s body on stage during graduation.
After parting ways with Roger and strengthening
his own chapter of the Sunny Family Cult,
Elias got married and moved to a small Iowa
town known as Bettendorf.
Around the time of the new millenium, they
gave birth to their first and only daughter
and named her Taylor.
They kept their lives as cult leaders a secret
from their daughter for as long as they could,
about six years, before she snuck downstairs
and witnessed one of the rituals.
Apparently they had not heard of baby monitors.
Her parents tell her to keep the rituals a
secret, but Taylor becomes more and more interested
in the activities of the cult over the years.
As this gradually happened while Taylor continued
to grow up, an incident occured in the small
New York town of Mohawk.
In the year 2007, in a certain house, a Mohawk
man beats up on his wife, before going outside
to have a smoke.
He hears a girl’s laughter in the distance,
and after being out there for some time, his
wife comes out to check on him and discovers
his decapitated head.
It’s another five years or so before the
next interesting development with Elias’s
daughter Taylor.
The cult discovers that a copypat member of
their cult has killed a child in town.
This marks the first time that Taylor has
attempted to take an active part in the operations
of the cult.
Against her parents wishes, she sets out to
expose the copycat, putting herself in danger
before eventually being rescued by the cult
and facing her father’s fury.
"I'm gonna tell you this one time and you
are gonna listen.
You don't ever, ever do that again.
This whole thing, everything that we have
and are, it's me.
You don't change the plan, you don't say a
word, unless I tell you to."
The town of Harbor has developed into a much
more populated community since the birth of
the second Look-See in the 30s.
Now, the town has attracted a new monster
-- the Santa Claus like demonic creature known
as Walter who eats children who are awake
past midnight on Christmas Eve.
In 2012, Walter commits what is assumed to
be the first of a string of child disappearances
on Christmas Eve.
The episode is titled “Walter’s Revenge”
and while it’s unclear what this little
girl actually did to him to warrant revenge,
it must have been pretty bad, because he eats
her alive.
Her sister Delaney is a witness to this midnight
snack, and would spend the next six years
plotting a revenge of her own.
A revenge… on his revenge...
Can we call that a re-revenge?
But before that would happen, there is a week
where three Crypt monster stories all take
place at once in Harbor.
They are: Season 1 of Look-See, Troubled Youth
and Season 2 of Stoneheart.
Let’s start with Look-See who rises again
after 13 students at Harbor High are killed
via poison.
This causes Look-See to come after many parents
and family members mourning the children who
died, who are unable to release their emotional
ties.
Look-See forces the assumed killer to do his
bidding by leaving notes for all the other
victims.
One of these victims reads her note on the
door of a bathroom stall, because we have
really terrible public restrooms here in America,
and while she is unable to release her love
for her separated husband, she is somehow
able to survive the attack, leaving her in
the hospital with two broken legs.
Look-See appears to her again in the form
of her husband, but this time she’s able
to fight back and drive the creature away,
leaving her physically broken and emotionally
dead.
Not long after, Look-See forces her to write
the notes for it’s future victims.
Meanwhile, at a nearby school called Journey
High, a wolf-like creature runs amok, killing
several students with the assistance of her
master, a cheerleader named Eva.
Not long after that, a second incident takes
place at the local library, where it’s revealed
that this other girl has the ability to transform
into the monster.
And while all of this is going on, because
this town is REALLY having a bad week, a girl
named Rebecca inherits the power of the ancient
witch named Aponi.
The power takes over whenever she’s in the
presence of abusive people, and she uses it
to kill her alcoholic father.
She starts attending a support group for the
abused.
As she meets each member, Aponi helps her
take out all the toxic people in their lives.
One day, the two goth sisters follow her home
and witness Aponi’s power when Rebecca beats
up three guys who gang up on her.
The sisters become obsessed with her powers,
and attempt on two separate occasions to ambush
Rebecca to try and learn the power’s secret.
Little does she know, the group was just a
facade.
The group leader and the goth sisters are
in league with… you guessed it, the Sunny
Family Cult, in order to try to transfer Rebecca’s
power to one of them.
At the end of the season, they appear to have
succeeded in stealing the power of Aponi.
"The last reported Sunny killing was in 2015
in the Northern Iowa town of Bettendorf."
This is the last Sunny Family Cult incident
to be reported in the news, but that doesn’t
mean they aren’t active in 2016.
Taylor goes on a date with a college boy at
age 16, where they sneak into a swimming pool
and she lures him into a shed where she is
supposed to kill him in front of her parents
as a cult initiation, but she’s unable to
go through with it.
Her father is upset with her, so to make up
for it, she invites 4 friends over, telling
them her parents aren’t home.
The friends come over and play truth or dare,
but hang with me, this is much better than
that one movie… Taylor is dared to do 7
minutes in heaven with one of the boys, but
when time runs out, she’s the only one who
comes out alive.
She cuts the power and kills the other girl
they are hanging out with.
Then she stabs the other girl’s boyfriend.
She tells the last boy she likes him and invites
him to join the cult.
He refuses, so she kills him as well.
That week is the last week of school.
Taylor makes a new friend named Jaina.
Taylor starts feeling regretful about what
she’s done, and vents in her diary.
She finally meets Roger, who is posing as
a substitute teacher at her school in order
to keep an eye on her.
He would later come after Taylor and Jaina
with an axe while they are sneaking around
the school after hours in order to scare Taylor
into believing her family could be in danger.
Taylor, Jaina and her boyfriend Lance celebrate
Taylor’s seventeenth birthday as she struggles
between normalcy and her life in the cult.
As they are all leaving, Roger kills Jaina’s
boyfriend and leaves the Sunny Family Cult
calling card along with his body in the woods.
The stage is set for Roger to change his story
on the girls, pretending to be a police officer
investigating the killer.
Taylor connects this to the man who came after
her at the school, thinking that Roger has
a chance to catch this man, but not knowing
that that actually was Roger trying to trick
her.
He tells Taylor she might be in danger and
wants to take her in for questioning, but
instead, kidnaps her and drives her across
the country to a motel in the California desert.
They arrive there on May 21st.
Roger kills two tourists and the motel manager.
He introduces Taylor to the Crypt Tome, which
is still in his possession.
He tells her that he believes she is the girl
of 17 who will give him the power to transform
as described in the book.
Taylor is able to call her father for help,
but she’s also starting to have some strange
visions.
At one point, Taylor has a vision of every
Crypt monster to date; they are all connected
to this ritual Roger is trying to carry out.
Her father shows up to save her, but becomes
the fourth blood sacrifice in doing so.
In retaliation, Taylor gives Roger what he
wants by killing him, fulfilling the text
written in the book “the fifth will become
something” and beginning his transformation.
At some point after this, the Crypt Tome is
given to this mysterious man and taken to
the UK.
We’re yet to find out exactly how this happened,
but one can assume that Roger just had no
more use for the book.
There are a few Crypt series that don’t
have exact dates associated with them.
There’s the Door in the Woods which sees
the unleashing of the monster who murders
the entire town except for one girl, who loses
her arm as she seals the monster once again.
This appears to take place in the past, but
this may just be a society that has rejected
technology, because the monster, the Brute,
also appears in Hospice, the story of a haunted
hospital wing, which seems to take place a
couple years before present day.
The Birch only has a single episode out, but
looks to be more or less modern day, and the
plot is about the summoning of a forest dwelling
protective creature.
Soot is a grim-reaper like monster who reclaims
the lives of those who escaped death in a
modern setting.
I believe these all take place before the
events of Mohawk, which looks to take place
around April or May of 2018.
At the very least, we know that school is
in session, and it’s warm out.
Remember way back earlier in this video if
you were even paying attention when I mentioned
the man who was decapitated by the ghost girl
in 2007?
Well in 2018, a new family moves into that
same house after the father is fired from
his job in New York after getting too handsy
with his nursing staff.
The family struggles to adapt to the small
town, and the son, who is regarded as a freak
by nearly everyone in the story, has these
visions of the ghosts that inhabit the town.
The ghosts begin to attack his older sister,
killing her and hanging her up in the front
yard on their second night in town.
Upon discovering this, the Dad loses it and
goes after the son, proclaiming that he should
have been the one to die.
That’s when the ghost of the girl from 2007
starts messing with the father, before ultimately
completely tearing him apart with her chains.
The mother runs into the street to try to
get help, only to be ignored by everyone in
town, who are somehow being monitored by these
little packs with red blinking lights.
Before the mother is able to escape the town,
she too is run down by the ghost.
The fate of the son is still unknown.
The modern day events of Shelley can’t take
place long after that, as those take place
20 years after Shelley’s death, at the Avon
Manor High School Reunion.
Shelly comes back to life, and with the assistance
of Celine, exacts her revenge on the three
high school bullies responsible for her death.
She saves Heidi, the girl hired to assassinate
her, for last, and hangs her body before the
entire school reunion.
Having gotten what she wanted from Celine,
Shelley turns on her, to get revenge for how
she turned a blind eye to the three bullies
all those years ago.
Shelly cuts off Celine’s hand and takes
back the bracelet given to her by her boyfriend.
She takes it to the man with the Crypt Tome,
who uses some kind of spell to power it up
again.
The school administrators throw their best
man to try and cut down Shelley and prevent
anymore damage, but she defeats him, and she’s
able to successfully resurrect Oliver.
Together, Shelly and Oliver do away with the
rest of the corrupt administration, thus completing
their mission… for now.
What Shelley doesn’t realize is that the
strange man with the Crypt Tome pits her and
Celine against each other.
Celine comes to Shelley’s family home disguised
as Shelley, who has been dead for over 20
years now, and kills her sister and mother
before setting fire to the house.
The man who powered up Shelley’s bracelet
is behind it, and he likely wants to fuel
Shelley’s rage in order to motivate her
to do more of his bidding.
Our last story takes us once again, back to
Harbor for Christmas Eve 2018.
Six years have passed since Delaney watched
Walter kill her sister, and she’s been plotting
ever since about how she can exact her re-revenge.
She invites her middle school friends over
and together, they develop a plan to capture
Walter, using human bait and the holiday decorations
set up around the house.
They successfully capture Walter, but foolishly
leave him alone to untie himself while waiting
for someone to pick up the body and dispose
of it.
Come on Delaney, you were this close.
When you’re dealing with Walter you gotta
wish him a Merry Christmas AND a Happy New
Year.
Walter gets out and attacks one, if not all
of them.
At some point he escapes, and goes on to devour
another little girl at another house.
I think the interesting thing about these
Crypt monsters that sets them apart from one
another is that each one represents something.
Those of you who watched the previous episode
of Horror History probably recognized Mordeo
as Crypt’s interpretation of a Wendigo,
which warns against the taboo of cannibalism.
Shelley is all about karma, that which you
do to others will come back to you.
Look-See represents lingering feelings and
regrets.
Aponi is all about the power to stand up for
oneself against abuse and trauma.
And the Sunny Family Cult focuses on themes
of individuality and finding your own path;
fighting for your own values.
This does not mark the end of the Crypt monster
universe though, far from it.
There are new entries into the Crypt lore
being uploaded Fridays on Crypt TV, and coming
in May a new series FIGHT NIGHT, where Crypt
monsters will be facing off against humans
in epic cage matches, so make sure you’re
subscribed to their channel as they continue
to fill in some of the missing gaps on this
timeline and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.